he's a Reggie Aloysius Miller the
hall-of-famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
fresh off calling the Western Conference
Finals as we get ready for Game one
coming up tonight
in the meantime reg let's talk about the
76ers and Bryan Colangelo story how do
you think this ends I'm sure there'll be
a meeting of the minds behind closed
doors you know when I first saw this and
read this I thought to myself this is a
career killer whether it's true or not
as you know sometimes leaks or
allegations are probably just as worse
as it actually being true so right now
the taint is already out there and when
you have your star players already
responding to it remember I know they're
young but they're working on rookie
deals and these young players in today's
game they have long memories so whether
you wrote it or not your wife wrote it a
friend wrote it they were your accounts
or not you said you knew one of the four
regardless it has your name written all
over it could be a career a career
killer because these young players today
are very sensitive they have long
memories and they're taking note and
especially when your best player comes
out and you know indeed wasn't going to
hold back and I liked what he said that
he doesn't believe it but still for a
general manager a president to be
associated with something like that it's
a little sad frankly if you were a free
agent but this impact you if you were
considering this 76ers absolutely not
this is a team on the rise really and
this is oh this was no not at all um
because the embarrassment is already out
there you know it's not gonna happen
again and you're looking at the makeup
of the team this team is gonna be around
for the next barring injury now barring
injury for the next seven years or so
great young nucleus so know if I'm a
free agent and I want to win and
especially in the East
it would not sway my decision whatsoever
if the Rockets I think I think the owner
at the end of the day is going to make
an executive decision here if he thinks
it's an embarrassment or he does not
think he can get free agent
then yeah Bryan Colangelo will be gone
but if I'm LeBron James just this does
not hurt me thinking I know that general
manager is an idiot I'm not going there
no I would be like Ben Simmons Joel
embiid
future you called the Western Conference
Finals we debated this after that game
Game seven when the Rockets missed 27
consecutive threes I know that a shooter
keeps shooting but there are certain
guys who should keep shooting in certain
guys who shouldn't keep shooting at what
point did you think did you say during
the broadcast how about driving to the
hoop how about something you know try to
get a like something to break up this
street here of 27 consecutive misses a
leopard can't change his spots you live
and die right so they've been playing
like this all season long and coming
into the playoffs they were very heavily
isolated team and Durham or Aidid
general manager president of the Rockets
that in D'Antoni that's what they came
up with threes layups and free-throws
there mid-range game is non-existent and
it just reared its ugly head at the
worst time but I gotta borrow something
reg I have to get something you know why
not try a layup get to the hoop why not
try to get a foul I think they were they
were trying they were trying to get
layups - but I like I was the master at
this how about one dribble a couple
steps in and shoot a 19-footer 17 footer
you know that sets up the rest your game
I you know the notion that the mid-range
game is gone
to me it's sad because that was people
want to assume that all I did was shoot
threes no my mid-range game allowed me
to shoot threes so it just baffles me
that they wouldn't take a long -
especially when you're struggling but in
the middle of it Dan
you can't tell me Trevor Ariza who was
what over 12 in that game and OH
eight or nine from threes born in James
Harden these were the principal shooters
have you missed 27 they didn't know they
had missed 27 in a row
they were just jacket they were just
jacking and doing what they do best
yeah just I watched it and once you
start to miss now it can play with your
mind if you're not ready for it you know
guys who were great scorers or shooters
know that eventually it'll click it's
the guys who aren't great scorers and
great shooters that's when they get in
their own head and now they're going oh
my god if I miss another one or I miss
another one so that's where I thought
not everybody needed to be shooting
threes that you needed to force
something I had to get you had three
fouls on klay Thompson like I there were
things I just looked at it as a an
opportunity loss and I don't think
Huston ever gets this close again not
with this group two to play for an NBA
championship just don't here was here
was a clear indication you it's the body
language of the fans and I don't know if
this played through the telecast but
obviously you could hear the noise you
hear how loud it was in there when they
started that run of 27 missed threes the
cheers started to go to moans and groans
maybe that should have been an
indication because it was tense
obviously Game seven you know you're
going home for both teams so when the
threes started to mount up and it wasn't
like these were contested threes then a
lot of these were they were wide open
threes that were and I will say this for
a reason and even maybe Gordon at times
I think the toll defensively that they
were trying to put and they did
throughout this series put on Durant
because he ever pick it up full they
were over playing I don't want to make
excuses but it took their toll on their
legs they had zero legs when they were
taking these shots true and again it it
it just showed it the worst time the
same that you could make the same case
for Boston you know that was the worst
time to go six for 39 they have been
pretty good from three and the Rockets
that shot pretty good from three but it
did it showed in Game seven Reggie
Miller joining us
if Houston was in the finals
Cleveland who would be favored Cleveland
oh yes I felt Cleveland was rooting for
Houston to win that series okay because
I think LeBron James and an
inexperienced Houston team I think
personally I would have picked LeBron in
the cows but now these should get a
4-peat you kind of know what's gonna
happen
personally how big of an underdog should
the Cavs be in this series well I will
say they do have this going for them
maybe you know better than I do I don't
know the availability of Andre Iguodala
and how healthy he will be because his
defense guarding LeBron James will be
huge we saw how important his loss was I
mean they needed to gain seven to be
Houston his interval in availability was
huge not being is not necessarily
defensively but even after the offensive
end
he gets everyone in the right spot him
and draymond Green offensively the ball
swings it doesn't stick the Warriors
really were reverting to what Houston
does a lot of isolation plays for Kevin
Durant so I think that's what the Cavs
have going for them if he plays and he's
healthy I personally have the Warriors
maybe in five I want to give LeBron
James six games just because of what
he's done during the playoffs and we
don't know about Kevin Love will we be
ready tonight you know these are all
questions that I'm sure leading up to
game time will be dissected in and out
but you know those are two things I want
to see what's going to happen here in
Game one the availability of Kevin Love
and that concussion protocol and how
healthy and how mobile is Andre out
there coming off that bone bruise if you
were the Rockets what would you do with
Chris Paul he's 33 years of age got a 5
in oliel there right in front of you
they don't win games four or five
without Chris Paul but do I want to give
you five years reg of two hundred
million dollars no I don't now we've got
to get into a locked room and we really
to talk about this but I would still
give him five years I never want to talk
about another 100 Monday's day one fit
150 to 170 yeah look these dudes follow
Chris Paul and he is a shot-maker
and he demands everyone excellent and
when he could not get off the floor and
immediately we knew they have we knew he
wasn't going to play in Game six or
seven he could barely walk he could
barely get up from the seat after they
got him to the bench so we knew he
wasn't going to play but they don't win
Game four or five without him
so I think that's how important he is to
the team and right now I go full-court
press trying to get you know who from
Cleveland but does that work to get you
know whom with guys who love to have the
ball you said you know you've left you
can't change your spots here and harden
is hardened all of a sudden not gonna do
ISO ball and Paul not gonna do ISO ball
cuz LeBron is gonna do ISO ball - well
you need more shooters better shooters I
should say more consistent shooters but
that's a pretty good trio you know Chris
Paul LeBron James anyone but what would
it work well first of all LeBron was in
the finals for what eight straight times
but right now he's already on a team
he's committed to a team for another two
weeks
but yeah I think it could work if you
surround them with the right people I
mean I love Trevor Ariza
I know the numbers don't show in Game
seven but what he does for your team
Eric Gordon was any consistent all
season and in the playoffs but he did
have big moments but I would love to see
LeBron stayed number one with Cleveland
because I love your marquee player the
best player in today's game in small
markets so our number one I would loved
it but if he is to move I mean I mean
obviously Philadelphia Houston to me
those are the two likely destinations
well I think he's gonna stay with
Cleveland for another year yeah but he
now he needs help this is a guy that
played in every single game and led the
league in minutes at 33 year 34 year
of age and in his 15th season and had I
voted for him for MVP that can't happen
he's got to have help if he wants to
stay in Cleveland so Dan Gilbert I don't
know how you're gonna get another
superstar maybe Paul George goes there
now Paul George goes to Cleveland I like
that yeah I like it
yeah you still got some dead dead weight
there though you do yeah but what look
for what LeBron did I know people love
to hate on it and I'm tired of the
comparison of MJ can we look okay let's
enjoy both of them
we can't keep saying who was better
who's the goat
we can't yeah we're done with players
yeah we're not doing that do it anymore
yeah I'm not yeah I'm not going to not
do it I am going to appreciate LeBron
James in this moment just like I
appreciated getting my head beat in by
Michael Jordan in the moment I
appreciate it growing up in Riverside
California watching Kareem abdul-jabbar
I heard stories from my dad about Bill
Russell I'm going to enjoy their legacy
I can't pit these guys against one
another because you can't pit eras it's
easy it's nice water cooler talk but
LeBron is fantastic Kobe unbelievable
ten Duncan I just can't do it guys I
can't I'm appreciating their talent and
what they've meant to the game and to
the younger generation but LeBron James
and what he did in this it's you know
and a lot of it is old-time players
they're they're hating because we all
wish I do
we all wish that we could be LeBron in
his 15th year when we got older we
sucked and a lot of old-time players
want to hate because they wish that they
were that good in their 15th year and
that productive and that dominating so
they want to hate don't hate it
appreciate man appreciate what this did
do I know sometimes he brings it on
himself and that's when you know I
scratched my head and got a pool LeBron
back but I'm going to appreciate in 15
years what he has done it's it's unheard
of
Theodore unheard-of I know I've been a
echo those sentiments I've been saying
that that you're gonna you're gonna have
this entire career play out in front of
you and then after the fact that people
are going to appreciate LeBron James it
feels like we're talking about here so
on your show I told you towards the end
of Kobe's before the Achilles injury man
y'all better appreciate this enjoy it
because when they're gone it's gone
but also we were talking about this
earlier if if Kobe came before Michael
it feels like Kobe was that what's the
bridge star or if he came further after
Michael it just feels like it was too
close to compare the two and and Kobe
wanted to be Mike wanted to look like
Mike act like Mike have his tongue out
like Mike shoot like Mike be an assassin
like Mike that that hurt him because it
was so close to him you could compare
him and then you realized that Michael
was a better player well said and I
believe there's a video on YouTube that
has both of them synched up with the
array of Michael Jordan shots and the
way they walked the fadeaways at the
tongue the expressions afterwards and
they're synced up side by side and it's
like you're looking at a mirror and at
times that hurts Kobe but what does it
hurt Kobe is those five championship
rings okay so you could say what you
want to be a clone and to be in the
shadow and to be probably the one player
closely related to Michael Jordan if I'm
Kobe I take that I would take that
that's okay with me
that's alright yeah it's just we want to
categorize people before they're even
done up appreciate we got appreciate
what what LeBron has done don't hate and
I don't know you didn't have a vote this
year and you know cats out the bag
already told you who I voted for and as
much as I love the season that Harden
had I think if you got a vote now who
would be your MVP LeBron but I LeBron's
the MVP of the league
it really it starts and ends that way
I understand look James Harden given MVP
or Russell Westbrook jr. the third give
him one okay that's fine it's a new
story I know how this works
LeBron is the most valuable player the
way Jordan was the most valuable player
Karl Malone let gibbon MVP Charles
Barkley an MVP new story great story
good but you know this is here's another
thing can you see the comparison now
I'll be careful when I do this LeBron is
similar to Tom Brady and and Michael
Jordan with Joe Montana if we're looking
at two different sports of a guy you
know two guys who didn't lose when they
played four championships but two guys
now who may lose but they're playing in
far more championships and the playoffs
were different when MJ was coming up
some first rounds were the best of three
and then they moved to the best of five
well LeBron has played in the era where
in the first round it's the best of
seven so when people say he's played in
more games well he had the opportunity
to play in more games than MJ just like
Montana and Brady the playoff systems
were different more teams now for LeBron
versus when MJ came in I believe there
was only 24 teams where there's 30 now
so the opportunity for LeBrons numbers
to be greater is because of the arrows
that are different between the two
players and we like to hold on to ghosts
you know the players that grew up with
MJ I grew up on the Montana and that's
why I feel when I see Tom Brady and
great is he is all I remember is the
pass to Dwight Clark I'm Joe Montana
that's all I think about of quarterbacks
is Joe Montana and it's crazy for me to
think about that because it's a
brilliance of Tom Brady we want to hate
I wanted to hate I mean I'm done with
that man I'm appreciating what Tom Brady
is doing in this 15th year to 16th years
I mean for him to continually get back
to Super Bowls win or lose to will his
team and all the changing parts think
about this all the changing parts that
New England has had over the years and
this dude still finds a way in the AFC
to get to the Super Bowl would you
rather
Tom Brady's career LeBron James well
since the Super Bowl was seen by more
people in the world I would probably say
Tom Brady just because you're seeing by
more people the Super Bowl is the Super
Bowl I mean that average is almost what
80 to 100 million eyes once a year yeah
but the bigger he's bigger worldwide
than Tom Brady is you think oh yeah
everything - I got a supermodel wife no
no no no no I know I'm not factoring
that and that's part of his popularity
of Tom Brady oh okay if I went into
Africa
do they know LeBron James or Tom Brady
Ron James if I go into yeah if I go into
China they're gonna know Tom Brady or
they're gonna know LeBron if I go into
South America they're gonna know LeBron
or Tom Brady
okay LeBron don't hate appreciate
Oh Tom Brady okay how about this one a 1
B who's the second most famous American
athletes with it so if you have LeBron
James
it's a is it Tom Brady is it Tiger Woods
who's more famous Tiger Woods or LeBron
James
tiger or sarena oh yes let's not forget
about Serena how about that oh so you're
going to bran Serena
hi Brady I'd still go El Tigre - and I'm
talking Fame worldwide yes we're going
worldwide who's famous LeBron James one
and then Serena yeah Louise the most
famous right now not retired like who's
still in the game well Tigers sort of in
the game yeah no no he's still in the
game okay
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go LeBron is the
most famous athlete in the world of
those who are still competitive and then
Serena and then I'm gonna go I'm so I'm
gonna still go Tiger Beat I'm gonna go
tiger and then I'll go Serena Tiger has
not been relevant since when 2010 ten
years ago eight years ago something like
that 2008 Serena just wan the Australian
Open last year yeah I know but she's
been she's been famous for 20 years
Tiger Tiger was more famous at his peak
of being famous than Serena why I agree
okay famous didn't bran Tiger was yes
Tiger was the greatest Ali was more
famous at his peak of being famous than
Tiger could you imagine if Ali was in
today's social media and all that air
today it wouldn't even be close it would
not even be close
oh he would be awesome he would be great
all right I have to run I there's other
things that we have to do here Reggie
it's like we're back in Indiana at the
bar me you and Mark smoking cigars and
having a good time conversation time
just flies that was the most fun I think
I've ever had involving a sports debate
where it was you and Mark Jackson going
at each other and I just I it would be
like I like Montana
I like Moreno then they go a lot of fun
all right reg all right let's talk soon
that's a Reggie Allah wishes for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]